e aspirano week ne ha vissute direi che
è stata una buona idea fare questo video
[Musica]
benvenuti ad una nuova puntata del
leccio con karim usa è quindi alla fine
ci siamo
il video dei video per chi non lo
sapesse nel video precedente avevo
chiesto alla gente di mandarmi delle
clip di pochi secondi a tema horror con
dentro una clip che gli avrei fornito io
e figurati se io non mi sia cagato
addosso per questo esperimento perché
noi sappiamo benissimo che fine fanno le
clip in green screen
se le dà in pasto a internet cazzo solo
detto che lo sappiamo lo sappiamo non
c'è bisogno di far vedere nessuno rvm
devo dire però che mi avete stupito io
qui lo dico e qui lo nego non ho mai
riso così tanto in vita mia guardando
quello che mi avete mandato e oggi vi
mostrerò le migliori in quello che tutti
avete pensato fosse uno speciale di
halloween quando in realtà vi odio
gabbati li ho fregati non è uno speciale
di halloween ma è uno speciale degli
undici anni del canale
non so perché non ve lo abbia detto
prima forse per lasciare tutto il più
naturale il possibile però a ottobre è
stato il mio undicesimo anno del del
canale direi che sono tanti e questo
video è quasi un regalo a voi per
ricordarvi che voi siete i protagonisti
di questo canale esattamente quanto lo
sono io quasi i tutti i soldi me li
pappo io però voi guardate e bastano 6
da cosa avevo capito che eravamo partiti
col piede giusto per questo video perché
la primissima mail che mi è arrivata e
un ruolo tex enorme di premi per i beni
penney ovunque
questa è la prima cosa che mi è arrivata
miglior pubblico di youtube italia baby
because this is thriller thriller nights
and nov ascona 6 view from the beast
about to strike you know this is
thriller thriller night cioè se è questa
clip veramente horror prova a farla
vedere a qualche youtube e dimmi se non
si caga addosso c'è da dire che
moltissime clip non erano neanche a tema
horror ma cavolo se siete stati bravi
mazzarri
vera e integrabili qui ci sono io
protagonista di interstellar qui ci sono
io protagonista di uccelli qui ci sono
io nella cover di albachiara sono sono
lì non so se si vede però sono fiero di
voi perché nessuno mi ha mandato neanche
una clip di bellerio ma neanche verza e
anche perché sarebbe stato facilissimo
fare una clip banale di giovanissimi
però mi sono arrivate un paio belle di
una dove ho anche il naso rosso e il
rossetto cazzo hai fatto un lavoro di
tracking della madonna complimenti e
l'altra sono scoppiato a ridere quando
l'ho guardata perché non è un trailer di
it e un trailer di yacht se l'avete
capito per alcuni l'inferno sono cattini
gattini ovunque direi
per altri invece è semplicemente una
porta tra le fiamme che si aprì nel buio
con le tendenze di youtube italia dietro
hai capito gli intenditori e poi uno mi
ha infilato in uno dei vecchi intermezzi
di rete 4
[Musica]
[Applauso]
uno dei miei sogni nel cassetto
questa mail dice soltanto [ __ ]
[ __ ] poi
e semplice ma funziona
mi piace e poi ci sono quelli che ci
hanno speso del tempo per farla infatti
si vede perché sono horror e sono ottime
bravi bravi
[Musica]
altri invece molto meno
signora c'è un uomo per lei guarda manda
un abbraccio alla tua famiglia è tanta
ma tanta fortuna per il futuro
uno ha capito perfettamente il mio
incubo quello di finire in google
immagini in mezzo ai miei meme
influencer ce ne sono alcune che hanno
una cura per i particolari che guarda
ora immaginate di essere un adolescente
squattrinato durante i saldi di steam il
vero orrore dio
in quei momenti potrei morire di questa
non posso dire niente adoro il piede di
porco nella mano questa prossima clip
potrebbe turbare le persone più
sensibili quindi vi ho avvertiti no non
c'era la censura l'ho messa io non so
cosa dire voi ormai mi conoscete
benissimo perché sapete che adoro i
colpi di scena finali mi sto guardando
una semplice clip ambientata nel mondo
di isaac quando ad un certo punto
all'improvviso dal nulla
boh così il colpo di scena enorme
testone di saba q che ti guarda con gli
occhi che brillano era un bel colpo di
scena si cozzava bene con la clip
assolutamente no e a proposito di sabato
è stato molto gentile da mandar bene una
mi ha fatto finire in un'altra
dimensione in compagnia di ricche morti
veramente di classe grazie e a proposito
di ricche morti
perché no voglio dire vi adoro anche il
buon gatto bene ha mandata una mi ha
fatto disintegrare dai tripoli della
guerra dei mondi almeno ho conosciuto
tom cruise e voi io ci sto io ci sto io
ci sta no sono solo no qualcuno ha usato
la mia mail per creare un account di
pornhub
[Musica]
[Applauso]
questa clip di stringer teens è molto
carina però permettimi un consiglio è
voilà siccome la gente ha un sacco di
fantasia mi sono arrivate qualcosa come
duemila clip di share canado ma questa è
la più bella è un reverse green screen
ha lasciato il green screen e ha tolto
me con dietro una locandina di shark
nadeau ti voglio molto bene questa clip
invece è falsa perché io mai e poi mai
scapperei da golberg mai
[Musica]
e per finire questa splendida carrellata
di clip il genio lori buona sera
[Musica]
[Risate]
qualcuno è possibile e siccome siamo
alla fine di questo video io dovrei
farvi dei ringraziamenti dei
ringraziamenti enormi per tutti questi
anni di lavoro tutti questi anni di
passioni tutti questi anni di
soddisfazioni anche grazie a voi
dovrei ringraziarvi perché mi permettete
di avere un lavoro che mi piace e di
conseguenza di vivere una vita decente
ma non lo farò
in cambio vi faccio vedere questo lo so
lo so che l'ha già fatto più di pai non
rompetemi le balle porca put
ambara ba
cc cocco